thank you for the invitation to present
today and i've
i've been asked to present on test
validation in medical laboratories from
an australian perspective um and so
i'll give some context as to where i'm
based and what we do
first so i i
am based at the garvin institute of
medical research which is in sydney uh
it's a beautiful part of the city you
can see from this image
and i've highlighted some of the
the affiliated institutes and hospitals
uh with the garvin institute of medical
research
we have some vincent's hospital the
kinghorn cancer center where i am based
and the garvan institute as well as a
medical school nearby and the victor
chang cardiac research center
so at the garvin institute there are
around 600 scientists
and clinicians but there are more than a
thousand
scientists and clinicians across the
precinct
so it's a very uh rich grounds for
collaboration and for clinical projects
the lab where i'm based and that i'm
director of is
at the kingoran center for clinical
genomics and air lab is the
largest dna sequencing facility in
australia
my research my experience sorry in
research and clinical
testing spans around 20 years as a
cancer researcher i studied
the genetics and epigenetics of
hereditary and sporadic
bowel cancer i was a group leader at
unsw
starting 2009. before that i was in the
uk
and then since uh leaving unsw
i've been in leadership roles in genetic
pathology
first in a private pathology company
known as douglas hunley moya pathology
those of you in the u.s may know this as
sonic healthcare
the headquarters of sonic healthcare is
actually dh
and dhm in sydney and i was the
supervisor of the genetics lab there and
since uh
then i've been laboratory director at
the kinglorn center for clinical
genomics sequencing lab
and in that time i've overseen the
validation and natural accreditation of
multiple single gene
gene panel whole exome and whole genome
services
but that just brings uh my expertise
to highlight why i've been
asked to give this talk and hopefully
shed some light on
what test validation for clinical
testing
is like in australia
my lab is an iso 15189 accredited lab
and also natal accredited for germline
whole genome sequencing in 2016
germ line hole exome sequencing in 2018
and most recently
somatic gene panel testing in 2020
so iso 15189
is a set of australian or international
standards actually
for operating clinical laboratories
and it builds on other standards
such as iso 17025 which is focused on
technical
uh requirements but the iso 15189 is
really focused on clinical safety
so how samples are handled within a
clinical lab
now when it comes to nasa this is an
australian based organization
and so let's go into these in more
detail because it's really important to
understand what these are because they
guide
how we validate tests
in a clinical lab
is the national association of testing
authorities
it provides us administrative support
it provides the assessors to assess a
lab
to determine whether they should and
could offer clinical testing
and it provides the infrastructure
around those
the royal college of pathologists of
australasia they provide professional
advice training and support and work
hand in glove with nata
and npac the national pathology
accreditation advisory council
are a ministerially appointed council
which basically provide
the requirements that a medical
laboratory must follow
in order to perform clinical testing and
natal will assess
a lab based on the requirements that
npac publish
npac have a series of standards
documents separated into tiers which are
used as a
as a a guide to
validating new tests and operating
clinical lab and i've listed them here
so iso 15189 as i mentioned is an
international standard
that outlines the requirements for
quality and competence for medical
laboratories
who perform testing in clinical or
diagnostic settings it's focused on the
clinical and technical validity
patient safety and risk reduction of any
operation within a lab
and as i mentioned there are other
standards that
this builds on such as iso 17025 which
is more focused on technical competence
but in addition the iso 15189 is focused
on management system requirements that
are necessary for it to deliver
testing in a clinically and technically
valid way and what
does iso 15189 consider everything from
pre-analytical
steps such as sampling handling and
transportation
of a sample the validity and
appropriateness
of a method in the lab traceability
of measurements and calibration to
national standards
suitability of those
pieces of equipment for testing the
technical competence of staff which
should be documented and recorded and
continually improved
the quality management system and
also steps that the lab must take to
continually improve what it offers
and some of that involves customer
feedback and making sure that
complaints are addressed
so when it comes to validating a new
test in
an australian medical laboratory any
test that is developed
from scratch or a an off-the-shelf test
that is modified in any significant way
is known as an in-house in vitro
diagnostic medical device or an in-house
ivd the us equivalent would be known as
a
laboratory developed test or an ldt
and again there are requirements that
must be followed
in order to validate a test for clinical
use
as i mentioned npac but also the
therapeutic goods administration
and these are two documents that are
bibles i guess for medical laboratories
who wanted
to validate a new medical test
in terms of managing the lab there are
certain
pragmatic factors that guide
what tests would be validated
and everything from the workflow and the
equipment used
some of those pragmatic factors include
the scalability
and automation of a method
you want to reduce hands-on scientist
time where possible
it may be a test that's amenable or it
may not be amenable to automation
and some of those steps may involve
liquid handling robotics lims
integration
the automation of analysis with
bioinformatics
but also you have to factor in what the
cost of that automation
is you also have to factor in clinical
safety
and whether the test can be operated
with clinical safety in an iso 15189
environment
turnaround time of the test is important
it has to be
guided by the urgency of clinical
management
it makes no sense to have a test that
takes four weeks to perform
but in order to guide clinical
management a clinician may require a
testing three
test result in three days so that's an
important factor as well
and of course the cost cost as in
what's the cogs the cost of goods
for the lab whether
a charge whether the market would be
willing to pay
the cost and also in the australian
context whether there's medi
medicare rebate available that would
cover costs
when it comes to test validation there
are a number of
specific criteria that we need to
address
and this is standard across the world
nothing
too specific here in terms of the
australian context but we would want to
make sure that the test is accurate
is robust precise we need to define the
measurement uncertainty
of any quantitative measurements
and we need to understand the
limitations of the test
and whether there are any potential
causes of false
positives or false negatives and i've
defined
what those terms mean here
so rather than go through a series of
standards and documents that are quite
dry
necessary but quite dry i thought
instead what i would do is go through
my personal
view of test validation in a medical
laboratory
and i'm approaching this in this slide
from the perspective of a researcher
and having worked in a research
environment i'm aware of the way
or the disconnect between research
researchers and research projects
and a a lab that performs medical
testing in a regulated
environment now a researcher
often thinks along these lines
we have an idea does the test have
clinical utility
and along the way you would design a
method
that would be able to measure for
example
mutations in a particular gene you would
then
validate it and then you would have a
test with clinical utility
i think this is the wrong way of going
about
test validation it really doesn't
account for the many factors we need to
take into account
when designing a new diagnostic service
and that's really where we want to get
to a diagnostic service
that has clinical utility that is
clinically accredited and can be
used by clinicians to inform patient
management
that is profitable or at least has its
costs covered is scalable so that if you
receive
50 samples in a year you'll find but if
you receive 2 000 samples in a year you
can cope
that is clinically safe
quick with an appropriate turnaround
time for the clinical question being
asked and is also reliable
so to get to that point yes the test has
to have clinical utility
there also needs to be a business case
and as i go through these slides i'll
define in greater detail what each of
the factors and the the considerations
for each of these
then you design your method you
also need reference samples to test
during test validation which you then
perform and i'll come to the steps there
you need to your laboratory needs to
enroll in quality
assurance programs and this is uh
proficiency tests external proficiency
tests to make sure that your test
is detecting what it should you then
need to resource
the test that may involve training
the scientists to perform it and the
pathologist to interpret it
and then you need to market the test to
make sure that people know
that you have developed this and target
that towards
the most appropriate clinicians
so let me give you a case example in
this case i'm going to describe the
genetic testing
of a gene called ugt1a1
ugt1a1 encodes an enzyme that conjugates
bilirubin in the liver
and if it's not functional then
you end up with the accumulation of
bilirubin in the blood or
hyperbilirubinemia
this is also known as gilbert syndrome
but certain genotypes can also be
predictive
for adverse reactions to a range of
drugs
individual atazanavia
and irinatika indinovir and atazanavira
are used in the treatment of hiv
and irenitycan is used in the treatment
of gastrointestinal cancers
if given these drugs and if you have and
you have
gilbert syndrome you'll have
toxic side effects to to those drugs
so it has clinical utility
but is there a market for it this is
where the business case comes in
you need to understand whether people
will request this test
you need to understand whether anyone
else already offers it
and whether your test is predicted to be
more economical have a superior
diagnostic yield
be more efficient be safer and be
quicker
or you know have a decreased turnaround
time
the method design in this case can be a
simple
pcr and capillary electrophoresis based
method
so that's great because it's quick it's
simple it's easy it's
cheap
now the genotypes that
are diagnostic for gilbert syndrome and
predictive
of adverse reaction to specific drugs
are all located
within a specific region of the ugt1a1
promoter
it's a dinucleotide repeat and
there are only four clinically
actionable variants that we need to
consider
and if you're familiar with the
pharmacogenetic system
of haplotype calling then you'll be
familiar with the star allele system and
they are known as star 1
star 28 star 36 and star 37
so as i mentioned these variants are all
dilute dinucleotide repeat lengths
and they're all within the same location
so a simple pcr capillary
electrophoresis assay
and only four genotypes the number of
samples we would require
is quite small only 20 to 30 with
representative
examples of each of those genotypes
obviously if you were doing gene
sequencing across the entire gene
or a panel of genes or a whole genome
you would require many more reference
genotypes
to be assured that you're detecting the
full
spread of different types of alterations
that you may see
then comes test validation it will
include a
period of test optimization but then you
get on to
testing the specific criteria of
accuracy
robustness measurement uncertainty or
precision
the limitations and then writing
documenting a validation report which
will be submitted to nata
in the australian context
the quality assurance program step is
really important because
it's a regulatory requirement that a
lab involved in medical testing is
enrolled in some
form of proficiency testing and as i
mentioned before this is really
around making sure your test detects
what it should detect and
defining the false positive and false
negative rate
and that's also crucial for
understanding the limitations of the
test
now if there's no
if there's no quality assurance program
available
then the next best option is to
set up a sample exchange with a
laboratory that performs similar
testing and we've had to do that in the
past
as well
then you need to resource the test you
need to
make sure it's scalable cost the
pathologist time the scientist time
standardized where possible and automate
where possible and that may involve the
reporting as well as the wet lab work
you need to make sure that you have the
right number of scientists with
redundancy
redundancy in personnel and equipment
that is
and you need to consider that the other
services within your laboratory
aren't affected by this new service
and that could be in the resourcing
context
but also in the methodological context
is it going to require equipment that
would displace other important equipment
are there contamination risks for
example an amplicon based test next to
a non-amplicon-based test and
other considerations such as those
then you need to train your scientists
in the regulatory environment
you need to make sure that those are
those training exercises are documented
and that there are records for each
member of staff
who will be performing the test
and then finally marketing to your
target audience
with my latest flyers presentations
i often have to go and give
presentations to
to show clinicians and oncologists a new
test that we've developed
uh to explain to them the clinical
utility the test request route
uh and how this compares with other
tests
similar tests that are available
so once you've done all that uh you
submit
a validation report to nata
nafta will then if it's a completely new
scope of service and a scope of
accreditation that you're applying for
then they will visit personally with
technical assessors
and a natal lead assessor and they will
go through with a fine tooth comb
all of the processes that you've set up
that use that that test uses
everything from your quality management
system training records
sops the validation report itself
the way you store samples the way you
return results to
requesting clinicians
and then they deliberate and get back to
you within
a few weeks to potentially a few months
for a complicated
extension of scope
once you've been awarded accreditation
there's then reassessments and
surveillance visits
and these are the surveillance visits
are usually conducted every 12 months
following initial assessment but also
if you have recently changed the way
your lab
operates or your service you may get
a surveillance visit earlier than
expected
and then reassessments are conducted
every 24 months
so there are other important documents
as well
as i mentioned there's the iso 15189 iso
17025 the
mpac tiered documents some of which are
listed here
and there's also published literature uh
describing
standardized frameworks for the
validation and verification of
clinical tests and there's an example
here by
matak setel and with that
that's the end of my presentation and
i'll happily take any questions thank
you for your attention